[Music]
in august 2020
while europe was on the cusp of a
devastating second wave of covert 19
and the us was struggling to find beds
for its sickest patients with the virus
this was happening in russia
but the rest of the world wasn't so sure
russia has become the first country to
give regulatory approval to a covid19
vaccine
but there are myriad questions and
concerns already
a vaccine so quickly and from a country
notorious for propaganda
and deception
[Music]
the issue is not about the science of
the vaccine
it's about the approach that was used by
the russian government
in terms of approving and starting to
use the vaccine
before the phase 3 clinical trial data
was
in starting to use the vaccine starting
to try to export the vaccine
and like launching this entire
propaganda campaign
actually worked against the product
after first facing scrutiny on whether
russia's vaccines
actually work now the question has
become whether they can meet worldwide
demand
critics and observers are now left
wondering is the kremlin playing vaccine
politics as part of a campaign to
undercut western powers and their
technology
or is this a case of solid signs being
tainted
by allegations of russian hacking
poisonings and interference in
democratic elections
russia is scrambling to bring kobe 19
under control
russia is battling a surge in covet
cases
the virus came late to russia but it is
definitely here now
russia reported its first covert 19
cases in january in siberia and russia's
far
east by july officials reported almost
840 000 cases and more than 30
000 excessive deaths global health
experts however
have questioned the accuracy of russia's
data deeming the number of cove of
related fatalities too low given
infection rates
russia acted very swiftly to impose
restrictions it was one of the first
countries
to enact a total ban on the entry of
chinese citizens and by late march
it had imposed a shutdown of its borders
and a series of lockdowns across the
country
meanwhile in moscow the gamalaya
research institute of epidemiology and
microbiology
named after pioneering russian vaccine
researcher nikolai gamalia
got to work
they called the project sputnik v
[Music]
sputnik v is a reference to a a very
important date in in soviet history
which was
the launch of the the world's first
satellite
sputnik in 1957 and that marked the
the start of the space race between
soviet union
and the united states in naming it after
that
it's clear that russia was positioning
itself
as a player in a geopolitical struggle
the first artificial earth satellite a
world stirring event
by may the gamalia institute had already
started testing their vaccine on the
centre's director
as well as key scientific staff a move
which seemed to place russia ahead of
other countries in the vaccine race
the institute supplied vaccines for use
against the ebola outbreak in
guinea in 2017 to 2018.
the covert 19 vaccine that they
developed
was based on technology they had earlier
applied in an experimental
inoculation against the deadly middle
east respiratory syndrome
or murs and that's what allowed russia
to go ahead relatively quickly in
developing a covert 19 vaccine
but on august 11 when president putin
announced that sputnik had been
registered as the world's first covert
19 vaccine
it hadn't started vital phase 3 trials
prompting worry among the scientific
community
and mockery from the trump
administration
i was extraordinarily surprised to see
that announcement
in august i'm not surprised that they
were working on it not surprised they
started the clinical trials
but very surprised and a little bit
disturbed
to see them starting to use it before
they had the data
for putin it was clearly very important
to be first in the world
to release and approve of action
and so the entire state propaganda
apparatus worked overtime to present
this as
a huge victory for russian science
for the russian pharma industry and
basically as proof of russian
superiority
in in areas where the country has long
been written off
isn't it premature to for russia to have
approved this vaccine before
phase three trials are substantially
underway
you know not at all at first we were
criticized but then we saw that britain
announced that they may follow the suit
the us fda said that they may want to
register before phase three
the suspicion that this is a propaganda
tool
rather than actually a way to to fight
prophet 90
was obviously there and it was
expectable that reaction
the putin government has done a lot of
ugly things to earn
the the suspicion and distrust of
especially
western nations so obviously there was a
certain handicap to overcome and that
could not be done
with you know premature fanfare it could
only be
counteracted with scientific proof and
scientific proof was eventually
delivered
on february 2nd in the esteemed medical
journal the lancet
vaccine experts professors polly roy and
ian jones
reported that sputnik v appeared safe
with an efficacy rate of 91.6 percent
this was really a chance for for russia
to dispel a lot of the skepticism
uh surrounding the vaccine and
you know whether it was actually good at
combating covet 19.
i think it's fair to say that demand
increased as a result
of that breakthrough in europe there has
definitely been a change of sentiment
there are shortages of the vaccine in
europe
so you know now the eu is is looking at
a request
to approve the use of sputnik v
and in addition to that several european
countries
france germany spain and italy may
also manufacture it so it's definitely
fair to say that there was a change of
heart
either by their european medicine is
[Music]
sputnik is very similar to both the
astrazeneca vaccine
and the johnson and johnson vaccine in
that
it's an adenovirus vectored vaccine
and what that means is that they're
using
a common cold virus to
deliver a little bit of the covet virus
to your own cells and sort of tricks
your cells
into making just a little bit of
the covid virus and with that little bit
which is the spike
protein your body is able to mount an
immune response so you develop
t cells you develop antibodies that all
respond to cova 19 if you should get
infected in the future sputnik v is also
double vectored
which means that it uses a slightly
different version of the vaccine in the
second dose
so protection against covert 19 could
last longer
i don't necessarily think that in terms
of the vaccine
itself and how it works in the body it
exhibits any advantages over the mrna
system
now vaccines like sputnik like
astrazeneca and like the johnson johnson
vaccine that are all adenovirus vectored
vaccines
are much more stable in warmer
temperatures
and so that makes this cool chain much
easier
that means the storage and the
distribution is much easier
and so all of that is a real positive
strength the astrazeneca and johnson and
johnson shots
have in rare cases been connected to
blood clots
russian officials claim that sputnik
though developed in the same way
hasn't caused similar side effects all
of this combined with a relatively low
production cost of ten dollars a dose
makes sputnik v a viable option for
developing countries
that are struggling to either obtain or
distribute inoculations
but there are questions about how much
politics will impact the vaccine's
distribution
we do not do politics and obviously
vaccine is our effort to save people and
it should not be politicized
russia clearly has been using
the vaccine sputnik v as a way to to
bolster its global ambitions
in latin america for example argentina
has already had deliveries
of two and a half million doses it it's
ordered a total of 20 million mexico
is another big buyer they've they've
asked for 24 million
doses russia hasn't uh
asked any countries to pay a premium
however
it's not offering any discounts for
poorer countries so
in latin america or africa the price is
the same
as anywhere else and that's
approximately
10 dollars a shot and we know that some
western manufacturers
are are providing uh discounts for
for for developing countries
however russia's pharma industry wasn't
prepared for the level of demand for
sputnik v
the rdif russia's sovereign wealth fund
who are financing the vaccine
had to strike production deals around
the world to support the global supply
for sputnik v abroad
[Music]
they're definitely still problems in
ramping up production
russia's total production of sputnik fee
since the pademic
started is less than the number of
vaccine shots administered every two
weeks to the u.s population
it is now promising to
to produce much larger quantities
particularly in
india it has a very ambitious target of
700 million
two dose sets which is hoping to get
manufactured
outside russia this year
closer to home there's been a lack of
enthusiasm for the vaccine
with a recent poll revealing that 62
percent of respondents
wouldn't take sputnik fee
despite ordering mass inoculations in
january
putin himself didn't get vaccinated
until seven months after the august
announcement
the kremlin said he was focusing on
other inoculations
it was not made public which of the
russian vaccines he received
in a way that the traditional russian
mistrust of authority
has made it easier for
the government because the demand for
the vaccine is not as high as it would
have been elsewhere
in russia you can get it if you want it
uh but managers don't want to and
perhaps even putin's own
slowness and getting vaccinated is
indicative of
you know how cautious russians are about
this whole thing
russia has been hit especially hard by
the pandemic
with at least 250 000 epidemic link
deaths russian
officials said but the country could now
hold a powerful weapon in the fight
against the virus
i think the sputnik vaccine will be a
very powerful tool
i think we still have a few questions
that need to be answered i still think
we want to see the the final data at the
end of may when the
phase three trial is due to end and
all of the safety data so yes a few
small bits of data that i would like to
see but
i think the sputnik vaccine will
absolutely be a very powerful tool
in the global vaccine campaign as well
as
many other vaccines that are both being
developed right now
or being used in other countries we just
need to combine
that sort of manufacturing and
distribution with that solid
clinical evaluation and i think that we
are doing that
it's made a huge difference to to
russia's image definitely
a a very good tool of soft diplomacy
which has shown that russia
has a capacity to to play a an important
role in combating this pandemic
you